THEORY-LOVING PIP SQUEAK, ADAM
SHIFT.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE ON THE
TOP STORY IS THE PRESIDENT'S
FORMER ATTORNEY, JOHN DOWD, ALSO
THE AUTHOR OF THE INTRODUCTION
TO THE MUELLER REPORT, HARVARD
LAW PROFESSOR, ALAN DERSCHOWIZ.
MR. DOWD, COUNSELOR, I'LL ASK
YOU, I WOULDN'T WANT MY WORDS
TWISTED LIKE THAT CONSIDERING
WHAT YOU SAID WAS PERFECTLY
LEGAL AND PROFESSIONAL AND THE
THING TO DO AS YOU HAD A DEFENSE
TO LEAD AT THAT POINT.
>> I HAD AN OBLIGATION AS
COUNSEL TO THE PRESIDENT TO FIND
OUT WHAT WAS GOING ON.
AND I'M SO GLAD JUDGE SULLIVAN
ORDERED THE TRANSCRIPT.
WAS WE NOW KNOW THE TRUTH.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THIS ENTIRE
REPORT BY MUELLER IS A FRAUD.
AND WE'RE GOING TO FIND MORE OF
THESE THINGS.
ISN'T IT IRONIC THAT THIS MAN
WHO KEPT INDICTING AND
PROSECUTING PEOPLE FOR PROCESS
CRIMES COMMITTED A FALSE
STATEMENT IN HIS OWN REPORT.
BY TAKING OUT HALF MY WORDS,
THEY CHANGED THE TENOR AND THE
CONTENTS OF THAT CONVERSATION
WITH ROBERT KELNER.
IT'S AN OUTRAGE.
THERE'S PROBABLY MORE OF IT.
>> YOU KNOW, ADD TO THIS
PROFESSOR DERSCHOWIZ.
THAT IN AND OF ITSELF IS AN
OUTRAGE BECAUSE YOU ARE
LITERALLY CHANGING THE EXACT
MEETING OF WHAT THE COUNSELOR
SAID.
NUMBER ONE, NUMBER TWO.
HOW EMBARRASSING FOR MUELLER
LAST WEEK TO SAY I COULDN'T
INDICT ON OBSTRUCTION BECAUSE
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE RULE
THAT DOESN'T ALLOW OR QUESTIONS
THE ABILITY OF HIM TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION AS IT RELATES TO
WHETHER YOU CAN OR CANNOT INDICT
A SITTING PRESIDENT.
AND THEN A TEAM HE PUT AROUND
WITH ANDREW WISEMAN AND COMPANY
IN SYDNEY POWELL'S LICENSE THE
LIE.
PROFESSOR, YOU CARE ABOUT CIVIL
LIBERTIES, I CARE ABOUT CIVIL
LIBERTIES, EVERY CITIZEN NEEDS
TO BE CONCERNED IN THIS.
>> THIS IS A VERY, VERY SERIOUS
ISSUE.
THE DISTORTION OF THE DOWD QUOTE
IS VERY SERIOUS.
ESPECIALLY SINCE REMEMBER THAT A
REPORT BY A SPECIAL COUNSEL IS
ALWAYS GOING TO BE ONE-SIDED.
THEREFORE, YOU HAVE TO TRUST IT.
BECAUSE THE OTHER SIDE DOESN'T
HAVE A CHANCE TO LOOK AT IT AND
SHOW WHAT'S WRONG WITH IT THE
WAY IT WOULD IN AN ADVERSARIAL
SITUATION.
IF A LAWYER MADE A
REPRESENTATION LIKE THAT TO A
COURT AND SAID THIS IS THE
QUOTE.
AND LEFT OUT THE USUAL CONTEXT,
WHICH SHOWED, AS JOHN SAID, THAT
WHAT HE DISCUSSED WAS NOT ONLY
ABSOLUTELY PROPER, BUT
OBLIGATORY FOR A COUNSEL WHEN
YOU HAVE A JOINT DEFENSE
AGREEMENT TO FIND OUT EXACTLY
WHAT'S LIKELY TO BE USED AGAINST
YOUR -- YOUR CLIENT, THERE'S --
>> IT'S NOT INAPPROPRIATE.
>> NOTHING INAPPROPRIATE.
>> YEAH, HE SAID THAT.
>> WHO WROTE THAT PARAGRAPH?
WHO WROTE THAT PARAGRAPH?
>> Sean: I HAVE A GUESS.
>> THAT IS CRUCIAL.
I KNOW.
HOW DID IT GET PAST MUELLER, WHY
WAS IT INCLUDE IN THERE?
RIGHT FROM THE BEGINNING, I SAID
BEFORE THIS REPORT IS MADE
PUBLIC, IT SHOULD BE GIVEN TO
THE DEFENSE AND INCLUDING THE
FORMER DEFENSE ATTORNEY LIKE
JOHN DOWD, TO BE ABLE TO GO
THROUGH IT WITH A FINE-TOOTH
COMB, FIND PROBLEMS WITH IT.
FILE A REPORT STATING THE
DEFENDANT'S POSITION AT THE SAME
TIME, SO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC CAN
JUDGE WHICH IS MORE CREDIBLE.
THIS WAY IT JUST TURNS OUT A
ONE-SIDED REPORT AND IT TURNS
OUT IT'S TOTALLY DISTORTED.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
WE NOW HAVE THE FBI PROFESSOR
GIVING SPECIAL TREATMENT TO
HILLARY CLINTON IN HER
INVESTIGATION, ONE, THE
EXONERATION WRITTEN BEFORE
ANYBODY IS EVEN INTERVIEWED.
THAT NEVER HAPPENS.
ALLOWING OTHER PEOPLE, INCLUDING
A WITNESS, INSIDE THE ROOM WHILE
SHE IS BEING QUESTIONED BY THE
FBI.
THIRDLY, THEY DON'T RECORD IT,
THEY DON'T HAVE THE 302s, THEY
BRAG ABOUT IT.
STRUCK AND PAGE BRAG ABOUT
LORETTA LYNCH'S ROLE AND THERE'S
NO WAY THEY WERE NOT GOING TO
RIG THAT INVESTIGATION.
I KNOW YOU LIKE THE CLINTONS,
BUT I THINK YOU LIKE THE
CONSTITUTION, THE RULE OF LAW,
EQUAL JUSTICE AND APPLICATION OF
OUR LAW AS MORE?
>> I LIKE -- I LIKE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT WEAPONIZING OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I THINK WE HAVE TO USE THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM ONLY IN
EXTREME CASES.
WE HAD HERE AN INVESTIGATION, IT
MAY NOT HAVE BEEN THE PERFECT
INVESTIGATION, BUT JAMES COMEY
CONCLUDED AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT CONCLUDED.
>> Sean: YOU ACKNOWLEDGING THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN TO EVERYBODY
ELSE.
DOES IT?
>> SHE HAD DONE SOMETHING WRONG.
WELL, IF YOU'RE THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AND PREVIOUS SECRETARIES
OF STATE USED HOME --
PERSONAL -- PERSONAL E-MAIL,
THEN YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF,
WAS THERE ANY PRECEDENT FOR THIS
KIND OF PROSECUTION?
SO, I'M SATISFIED THAT THERE WAS
NO PROSECUTION OF HILLARY
CLINTON.
I'M NOT SATISFIED WITH THE WAY
IN WHICH THEY'VE GONE AFTER
DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK EQUAL PROTECTION OF THE
LAW REQUIRES LESS
CRIMINALIZATION, NOT MORE
CRIMINALIZATION.
>> Sean: JOHN DOWD, LAST FEW
WORDS.
>> SEAN, SEAN -- SEAN?
>> Sean: YES, SIR.
GO.
>> THEY NOT ONLY WENT AFTER
DONALD TRUMP, THEY WENT AFTER
HIS LAWYERS.
THAT PARAGRAPH THAT THEY PUT OUT
IN THAT REPORT IS A SMEAR OF ME
AND MY REPUTATION.
AND WHAT I USED TO BE A
PROSECUTOR, IF ANYONE MADE AN
ALLEGATION ABOUT A LAWYER, AND
WHAT HE WAS DOING --
>> Sean: OUTRAGEOUS.
>> IF HE WAS CROSSING THE LINE.
>> Sean: YOU CHECK IT OUT.
>> I'D GIVE HIM WHAT I -- I MET
WITH -- I MET WITH -- I MET WITH
MUELLER AND QUARLES THE WHOLE
TIME.
THEY NEVER SAID A WORD TO ME.
INSTEAD THEY PULL THIS.